today on the matt well show the parent
of a non-binary quote-unquote
seven-year-old provides us an
unintentionally illuminating and
horrifying look into the mind of a child
who's been indoctrinated into this kind
of lifestyle
it's very interesting we'll talk about
that also five headlines including the
senate cures racism by declaring
juneteenth a national holiday that's
exciting
the attorney general again speaks out
against the imaginary epidemic of white
supremacist violence
a climate activist group accuses itself
of racism
and disbands and newsweek claims that
there's a furious debate about that
video of a guy shoplifting a bag full of
merchandise from walgreens in san
francisco
but what is there to debate about
exactly we'll talk about that and much
more today on the matt walsh show
if you're looking for privacy on the
internet which you should be and we
should all uh
be looking for that and you may think
just searching the internet in private
mode
is all you need to do but that that
doesn't mean exactly what you think it
means
did you ever read the fine print that
appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school your internet
service provider
how can they see it if we and yet and
that we call it incognito
to really stop people from seeing the
sites you visit you need to do
what i do and use it expressvpn we think
about all the times that you've
used wi-fi at a coffee shop a hotel a
parent's house whatever it is without
expressvpn every site you visit could be
logged by the admin of that network and
that's true
whether you're in on incognito mode or
not what's more your home internet
provider can also see
and record your browsing data and in the
u.s they're legally allowed to sell that
data
to advertisers expressvpn then is an app
that encrypts all of your network data
and reroutes it through a network of
secure servers that you're
uh so that your private online activity
stays just that private
uh because you have a right to that
information not anybody else so stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.comwalsh
use my link at expressvpn.com to get
three extra months
for free that's expressvpn.com
to learn more every once in a while you
stumble
across something that really puts things
into perspective even if
in an unintentional way and that's the
case for a post
by a guy named tom rademacher who by the
way is the author of a book
you've never heard of called raising ali
how my non-binary art
nerd kid changed nearly everything i
know
of course you probably already sold
based on that title alone but here's the
synopsis
from barnes noble anyway it says
seven-year-old ali a funny anxious smart
kid with a thing for choir and an eye
for graphic art
was gravely under challenged in school
and also struggling with identity and
how to live
totally as themselves ali
begged to switch to a new school with
kids like me where they wouldn't feel so
alone or so bored and so they made the
change
raising ali as dad is dad tom
roddamacher's story
of that eventful and sometimes painful
school year parenting ali and relearning
everything every day what it means to be
a father and a teacher
as ali who is non-binary and uses they
them pronouns and prefers art to
athletics vegetables to cake and animals
to most humans
flourishes in their new school
rademacher is making an eye-opening
adjustment
to a new school of his own one that's
whiter and more suburban than anywhere
he's previously taught
with a history of racial tension that he
tries to address
and navigate that all sounds thoroughly
dreadful
it's also going to be tough for
rademacher to get his book
into the bookstores there's limited
shelf space because of the law that was
passed a few years ago
declaring that every parent with a quote
unquote non-binary or trans kid
must write a book about it and also
start in a reality tv show
but the book is not the point the point
is this tweet from rademacher yesterday
seeking to explain the inner experience
of a non-binary child and by the way
every time i say non-binary please
insert the air quotes around the term
because in reality of course there's no
such thing as being non-binary there are
males and females in the world and only
males and females and that's it
and that is a binary system nobody is
outside of it but in any case rademacher
posted this he said
i was talking with my kid who's
non-binary about a friend
whose child just also started using they
them pronouns
the parents were struggling to get the
switch right so my kiddo said
tell them to imagine that instead of a
person their kid is a swarm of bees
yes a swarm of bees now we're going to
assume
for the sake of this monologue that the
child really did say what he's quoted as
saying that is admittedly in most
similar situations an extremely dubious
assumption but
here there seems to be a deep and
important truth
though not the truth that rodomacher and
the supportive people in the comments
seem to think
speaking of which there were a lot of
responses to this tweet and most of them
quite positive
uh unfortunately i just want to read a
few just to give you a gist
of what people are are saying one person
says quote
i try really hard to use correct
pronouns sometimes i go through all my
kids names
five kids get to get to one that i mean
so my oldest
is used to me saying he she they them
name
i'm hopeless but i'm getting better i'll
try the b's trick
to which someone else responded it's
okay my mom does the same thing even
with
pronouns i use they them pronouns and
sometimes she'll call my sister she her
by they them pronouns another response
to the original post says
that's great i have a harder time with
they them than i did with switching from
he to her with my niece
and it's mostly because of of a whole
new usage for my old brain
if i ever gender my non-binary friends
it's not because i don't respect your
identity
it's because i'm a mess well i have to
agree with that last part at least
another comment this one from someone
with the username frontline teacher says
my trans friend and i were talking about
this a few weeks ago he sent his
favorite story to me about a guy
who brought an air horn to thanksgiving
and every time someone messed up his
cousin's pronouns
air horn that guy is kind of my hero
another says my kiddo is non-binary went
to see my parents for the first time
since last january
and since my kiddo came out and the
grandparents struggled with their
pronouns
i forwarded this along thanks for the
share and finally one more example says
maybe we should simply start calling
everyone they them
we already do so when everyone's when
someone's gender is unknown
a language divided by binary biological
gender is a poor choice
in a world where gender is a spectrum
that's remember we have that to look
forward to eventually
you you will be non-binary too and you
won't have a choice in the matter
but what world is that exactly being
referred to
because it's not this one in fact i
would agree that a language based on
binary genders would be a poor choice in
a world where gender is a spectrum i i
would agree with that
so if you ever find yourself on planet
zeptan or whatever where there are
dozens of biological sexes then you
should keep that in mind
in this world however on this planet
there are only males and females those
are the only options
none others exist but i said that the
swarm of bee's analogy touches on an
important truth
and it does indeed seem to provide an
illuminating glance
into the fractured and confused mind of
a child
who's been indoctrinated into left-wing
gender theory
bees are insects with with very little
consciousness individually
together operating as a literal hive
mind they're able to work as one unit by
communicating with each other
through the use of pheromones and other
signals of course a swarm mine is a
little bit different than a hive mind
because bees in a swarm have split off
from the hive and are now homeless
searching for a new location
to build a hive i'm telling you all this
partly because bees are fascinating but
also because
it gets it gets close closer to the
experience of a
non-binary or trans child than
tom rodemaker or the clapping seals in
the comments probably realize
a swarm of bees has no real
identity either collectively or
individually
no real consciousness and also no home
no fixed point
this is how children indoctrinated into
this cult begin to see themselves
they're not exploring a new identity or
discovering one
there is no new identity at all rather
they are deprived of identity deprived
of a firm
sense of themselves they're a swarm of
bees
as the kid allegedly said himself
formless homeless
lacking coherence and identity
now if you go up to a child raised in a
healthy home who's been
helped to develop a coherent sense of
his own identity
and you ask him to uh compare himself to
an animal
which any any kid is happy to do and
we'll have an answer on the ready
and with with a with a well-adjusted kid
who's been raised properly
he'll probably pick something fierce and
majestic and solid and understandable
something like a lion or a bear or a
wolf
if your child sees himself not as one of
those beautiful and ferocious creatures
but as a group of insects
not even one insect but a group
something has gone horribly wrong
and what's gone horribly wrong again is
that he has
no idea who or what he is he is
shapeless
in his own mind his identity is formless
and void
anxiety you know comes from the unknown
we're anxious about what we don't know
what we can't predict what we can't
understand
that means that the more that a person
is living on solid ground in a world
that's understandable and cogent to
himself
the less that he will be anxious so what
happens when you make
even a person's basic biological
identity unintelligible and muddled
what happens when you say to a child i
have no idea
who you are or what you are you can
decide that for yourself
even though you know nothing at all
about the world or yourself and there's
an
endless array of changing options just
choose one
i can't give you any guidance it's all
up to you also by the way your identity
could change 30 minutes later even after
you choose one nothing is firm nothing
is objective
nothing is lasting have fun
this is taking a 5 gallon bucket of
anxiety and
waterboarding him with it he is he is
now drowning in uncertainty
rather than revealing the world and
himself to himself which is one of the
most fundamental jobs
of a parent you've hidden both of those
things from him
you've made it all more obscure
you say that you can give your child
freedom by allowing him to be
whatever he wants but there's no freedom
in confusion
a human being can't be free if they're
not first a being
you know you must be something someone
in order to be free
you might as well drop your
five-year-old off at the airport with a
stack of 20s and say you're free go do
whatever you want anything at all
go anywhere that might be a nice treat
for your kid after he graduates or
something
but for a young child it's called
abandonment
and that's what all this gender stuff is
it's abandonment
neglect deprivation because you're
depriving a child
of what is most basic and essential
that is himself
now let's get to our five headlines
if you've been listening to the show for
a while you've no doubt heard me talk
about my helix mattress
which we have uh two now in our house
we're big helix fans
uh in the walsh household well if you've
hopefully taken my advice a guy into
helix mattress then you know the next
thing you need is a helix sofa
and whether you have the mattress or not
you still need to get the solvent helix
has left the bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form
and they're already making the best
sofas that i've ever seen or sat
in more importantly so what makes an all
form sofa really cool for starters it's
the easiest way you can customize a sofa
using premium materials at a fraction of
the cost of traditional stores
you know to do this normally it's going
to cost you a whole lot of money
and it's going to be way more affordable
with all form you can pick your fabric
uh the sofa color the color of the legs
sofa size
everything else that makes it a perfect
fit for your home and frankly for your
butt as well
all foreign sofas are also delivered
directly to your home with fast free
shipping
in the past if you wanted to order a
sofa it could take weeks or even months
to arrive
and you need someone to come and
assemble it in your home all form takes
just three to seven days to arrive in
the mail and you can assemble it
yourself in a few minutes so
you gotta take advantage of this to find
your perfect sofa check out allform.com
walsh and all form is offering 20 off
all orders for our for our listeners at
allform.com
walsh all right so last uh
show before i go on vacation for
several days you know a wrench was
nearly thrown into our plans
yesterday uh when we had to take our
youngest daughter
one-year-old to the emergency room
is a day before you know the trip and
everything's fine now she was she was
she was cleared after a breach she had
as possible concussions what we were
worried about
and she was clear and everything's fine
and um and she's she's healthy
i'm not gonna get into the whole story
except to say that she uh she
she apparently wandered into a game of
the flores lava
among the older kids and accidentally
got herself bowled over
by her brother pretty pretty hard fall
and honestly she's lucky that she
survived because she was waiting in lava
to begin with
um but hopefully hopefully we've gotten
our
our vacation emergency room trip out of
the way because there always seems to be
one a couple years ago it was me
blew up my achilles on vacation and now
we can kick back and enjoy i guess our
um our 15-hour or really it's a
19-hour drive with four children under
the age of nine
you know this is how much i hate flying
that i would rather do that but
in france in my experience people tend
to exaggerate you know the pain of
driving long distances with with little
kids
um i find it here's what i'll say i find
it to be and we've done it a lot
i find it to be no less enjoyable than
say
being buried alive in a box full of
rabid squirrels or so it's
you know it's a it's on that level i
know that sounds kind of horrible
and i guess it is so i'm not sure what
my point was there
but the good news is that uh is that the
sustained close quarters kind of
psychological torment really prepares
you in case you're ever arrested and
sent to gitmo or something which
frankly these days is not outside the
realm of possibility
um but we have uh a few a few things to
talk about before we
before i can wrap up in fact i've got we
call those five headlines it's probably
gonna be more than five because i got a
bunch of stuff and i want to get through
it's all going to be dated by the time i
get back some of it might already be
frankly um but we'll uh we'll get into
some of this so number one
the senate passed a bill yesterday and
this is going to go to the house so it's
not if it's not official yet but they
passed a bill
unanimously establishing juneteenth as a
national holiday
and i think we have some of the footage
of this
potentially historic moment let's watch
let's watch some of this
mr president i ask consent the senate
proceed to the consideration of s
res 269 submitted earlier today
the clerk will report senate resolution
269 designated
june 19 2021 as juneteenth independence
day
in recognition of june 19 1865 the date
on which
news of the end of slavery reached the
slaves in the southwestern states
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure
i ask unanimous consent the resolution
why not the preamble
um i don't know why i'm asking you that
question i should have an answer that
really i tell you why
because this is this is the end of
racism
this is this is the senate curing racism
finally
and i feel like that's historic it's
also historic because
all of these people who just found out
what juneteenth was like last year
now they just found out last year much
of the country just found out last year
what it is and now it is a deeply
important
holiday to them that should be
celebrated
not only in america but across the
planet and indeed probably
across the entire solar system um
here's what i'll just two quick things
about this
first of all in
looking at it objectively in a vacuum
having a holiday to celebrate the
abolition of slavery
makes sense makes makes a lot of sense i
could see that
but i have a problem and i've i've and
as you know i've been saying this
for years i am opposed in principle
to anything that is done to appease or
impress
a mob okay anything that is done with
fraudulent intentions
to appease or oppress them up and that
includes tearing down statues
it includes declaring holidays it
includes anything
if there is something worth doing
you do it because it's worth doing you
don't do it all in a mad
rush because you're trying to impress
the mob
or you're afraid of them or whatever and
that's of course what's happening here
it's not a coincidence that we had the
riots and we have all all of this
and blm um and now
they're saying oh you know what uh yeah
let's make juneteenth a national holiday
it's the same thing i said with with the
statues
but i i think a lot of the statues that
were torn down
were were not were not deserving of that
at all and uh and should have remained
based on their own merits there may have
been a few statues that
you could make a reasonable argument for
taking them down
but even with those statues i said all
along i
i oppose tearing them down now
under these conditions
all in one mad dash if it was not for
that if it wasn't for the mass hysteria
and a community just on their own got
together and said hey we don't really
want this statue let's take it down
fine but under the circumstances
that's where i think it becomes a
problem also
i also have another problem um
with p if you if you as the the
democrats do in the senate
if you hate america and don't think that
america itself is worth
celebrating and in fact you don't even
think anymore that
that it's it's worth standing for the
national anthem
and you also think as they would tell us
and have said that racism today is worse
than it's ever been
it's all been downhill
then i don't know if you're necessarily
equipped
to come up with new national holidays
i mean i i guess that's the deal maybe
we should make like okay you want to you
want to
make juneteenth the national holiday
abolition of slavery makes sense
sorry are you saying now that we can
celebrate america and we is that what
you're saying we can be proud of
americans
everyone should stand for the for the uh
for the anthem
july 4th comes along we celebrate that
and be happy and proud
putting all the apologies aside we're
moving past that is that what you're
saying
i think you really got to pick a lane it
would seem to me
all right uh we played yesterday the
video of a guy shoplifting in san
francisco from a walgreens though not
really shoplifting because you think of
shoplifting you think of a guy grabbing
something off the shelf sticking in his
pocket
walking out uh being
trying to be discreet about it that's
usually what you think of with
shoplifting
but not this guy he rode in on a bike
and uh
rode out casually with a garbage bag of
merchandise
um if you didn't see that video let's uh
let's play that video for you again
well the good the good news is you got
the security there
with the phones and they're filming oh
there you there he goes security guard
tries to do his
tries to do his job he makes a noble
attempt
grabbing for the bag what like
either you're going to try to stop the
guy from stealing or not and considering
you're a security guard maybe you should
try to stop him like
if you're not why are you there would
why have a security guard
at a walgreens in san francisco if if
they're not gonna
what is he what actually is he there to
do
to film it with his phone well you have
security cameras already
that's in a way that's gotta be a pretty
plush job
uh to be a security guard in san
francisco
if you don't have a job right now you're
looking for something but go become a
security guard in san francisco because
you don't have to do anything
your job is to you you're a figurehead
you just sit there you take a paycheck
and kind of wave at people as they as
they come in and steal things
but if that's if that's your approach
fine well not really fine but if that's
your approach
all right why even try to grab the bag
at all that's what i understand
but anyway the guy so he steals all that
merchandise from uh
from walgreens and we mentioned
yesterday how
this has been a big problem especially
not just in san francisco but especially
in san francisco
and company stores have been shutting
down there's like 17
i think it was walgreens or cvs believe
his walgreens 17 locations had to shut
down
because of this and when you start
having stores shut down what does that
mean it means people are losing their
jobs
and yet newsweek says that there's a
been a furious debate
that was sparked by that video
uh they report quote shortly after the
video was posted numerous social media
users expressed their own opinions on
the incident
with many sparking debate
um and then uh quotes various twitter
users i guess we don't actually need to
read that read those uh san francisco
supervisor
asha safai also responded to the video
by writing this is exactly why i held a
hearing on organized retail theft and
i'm
pushing for greater accountability on
shoplifting in san francisco
as his tweet noted safai held a hearing
last month with retailers
to discuss the increase in retail crime
in the city
according to the san francisco chronicle
here it is over the past five years
walgreens has closed 17 locations in san
francisco
among the remaining walgreens locations
of the city theft incidents are four
times the average number reported
in similar stores across the country
four times
um while speaking with newsweek sophie
said one of the most shocking things
from
from the hearing was to hear from
walgreens cvs safeway the gap
to hear them say that san francisco is
one of the epicenters for organized
retail crime in the united states
so they're having hearings about it what
do we do about this problem
uh they're they're asking themselves uh
i i
you know you could stop the people who
are doing this
and arrest them it's probably the one
thing that you could do
i don't know i don't know how much
discussion there really needs to be had
about it
but from what i could tell the debate
is um among some on the left
and are probably being generous by
saying just some
who are essentially claiming that this
is a is a victimless crime
and yeah you know what run it go into
walgreens steal all you want because all
you're really doing is taking from
this the guy who the ceo of walgreens
whoever that happens to be
now we know that all ceos are uh our
villains are bad people
unless it's like the ceo of planned
parenthood or something and we make
exceptions there
well of course even if you were
only quote-unquote only stealing from a
ceo
it's still stealing okay the basic
problem and i and i wish this didn't
have to be explained
the basic problem with stealing no
matter who you're stealing from
is that it's the thing you're taking is
not yours
this is what we that's why i teach my my
three-year-olds
you you can't take something that's not
yours that's the issue
uh but of course it's not the ceo
is the last person impacted by this
the people at the top of walgreens i
doubt they've suffered very much
financially from the fact that 17
locations
were shut down in san francisco the
people that suffer are
people that work there and lost their
jobs
so the logic that's given it's the same
thing we hear with the the defenses of
of rioting and looting we're told that
oh no this is this is
if you're taken from anyone you're taken
from the fat cats
which even if that was true it still
wouldn't justify it but it's not true
so this is an argument that's wrong on
on every conceivable level
all right next this is from the daily
wire it says
under the suggestion and guidance of the
um of the bypoc members of the group a
new zealand youth environmental
protest group inspired by teen activist
greta thuneberg
disbanded accusing itself of racism
school strike school strike for climate
that's the name of the group
um their auckland chapter wrote on june
12th quote
school strike for for awk for climate
auckland is disbanding as an
organization
this is under the suggestion and
guidance of the bipoc
black indigenous and people of color
members of our group as well as
individual bipark activists and
organizations
we're not holding any more climate
strikes in the auckland region
bipoc communities are disproportionately
affected by climate change so the fight
for climate justice
should be led by their voices and needs
not peca ones
makea means white new zealanders
apparently i'm probably pronouncing that
horribly wrong but
um the group continued and said that
there was an urgent need
to decolonize the organization
and then they continue from there and
explain how
the the by the bypoc members suggested
that the organization
should be destroyed and so the white
members said
okay well if you say so everything we
worked for we're gonna just toss it out
this
i mean this is this is an organization
that we started and it meant a lot to us
but uh if you're telling us that we
should just get rid of it then we will
this the the whole idea that
and we hear this a lot that uh
the communities of color quote unquote
are
disproportionately affected by climate
change
environmental racism and so on
how can that possibly be the case if
what we're being told about climate
change is true
alexandria cortes is telling us that
climate change is going to destroy the
whole earth
in like 10 or 11 years it keeps changing
i feel like the it seems as though the
time
the timeline has been 12 years for the
past like five years
they keep saying it's always 12 years
the destruction of the earth is always
12 years in the future which is kind of
interesting
but whenever it happens if it's going to
happen
that's what you're talking about you're
saying the entire planet
we're destroying the planet
so if the whole planet is destroyed
and the human race comes to an end how
can that disproportionately affect
a certain race of people
it's like a if there's a a
an asteroid the size of texas bearing
down about to collide with earth
gonna turn earth into a giant fireball
and you would have these white liberals
saying you know i'm really concerned
about how this is going to affect
communities of color
yeah it'll it'll affect them in a pretty
devastating way but also everybody else
um of course the answer is that climate
change is not destroying the earth but
that's what they claim
so i i don't know i don't know how
exactly
any individual group of humans could be
disproportionately affected
by the human race coming to an end
um okay next year we have merrick
garland attorney general
he uh has been on a terror recently
talking about the threat post by uh
white supremacists he talks about it a
lot
we still haven't really seen these white
supremacists
but he's he's telling us they're out
there and here he is once again
discussing this this dangerous threat
the number of open
fbi domestic terrorism investigations
this year
has increased significantly according to
an unclassified summary of the march
intelligence assessment
the two most lethal elements of the
domestic violence extremist threat
are racially or ethnically motivated
violent extremists
and militia violent extremists in the
fbi's view
the top domestic violent extremist
threat comes from
racially or ethnically motivated violent
extremists
specifically those who advocate for the
superiority of the white race
we keep hearing this from him this exact
line
actually he keeps we've heard this many
times
the greatest threat is the domestic
extremists specifically those
motivated by a belief in the superiority
of the white race
he keeps talking about it and yet we
haven't seen
these are either they don't they mostly
don't
exist or they've discovered some sort of
they have some sort of uh invisibility
cloak that they've discovered
which would which would certainly i
would agree if they have that then
and now i'm even more concerned
but how do they get away how do they get
away with doing this well as we've
discussed it's it's pretty clear it's
it's easy to say
that white supremacist violence is the
greatest domestic terror threat
when you've ruled out or decided that
the more the more severe
domestic terror threats aren't really
terror threats
so antifa anything about domestic terror
threats
or domestic groups that are out there
right now
committing acts of violence causing
chaos in the street
who's doing that first thing comes to
mind antifa also blm
but guys like merrick garland from the
beginning have said well accept them
they don't count because
antifa what's antifa it doesn't even
exist it's an idea in the hearts of men
and blm they're uh racial they're
they're racial justice activists
yeah they have a propensity to burn down
buildings and uh loot and kill people
but
you know it's that's just their way of
expressing themselves
so if you do that then yeah if you rule
out if you have a list of
the most dangerous domestic extremists
and everyone at the top you've ruled out
for one for one reason or another
which is always the real reason is
ideology and politics
uh then yeah eventually you're gonna get
down to white supremacists and well
they're the only ones left
also former fbi agent andrew mccabe was
on cnn
after this after these comments from
merrick garland
reacting and uh
he he was he was asked about the the
attack on the gop softball game a few
years ago
i want to talk about a domestic
terrorist attack
where you've got a far-left militant
showing up at a
gop softball game and trying to
assassinate a whole baseball field full
of republican politicians
that you would think now okay there is
domestic terrorism
ideologically motivated but andrew
mccabe says that maybe not really let's
listen to him
andy i thought it was significant the
attorney general said very clearly that
the fbi's view
the top domestic violent extremist
threat right now
comes from racially and ethnically
motivated violent extremists he's
talking about white supremacists but he
also took care to note extremism and
attacks
on all political parties on
all races and creeds and religions he
noted
the congressional baseball practice that
was attacked
only after the gunman had asked if they
were republicans
i thought it was significant did you
think that was significant that he that
he raised this
yeah it was okay and an incredibly deft
way to bring in that other side of the
equation
i mean let's call it what it is right i
think he came right out and said you
know our
our biggest hot spot right now is
racially motivated
ethnically motivated extremists and the
and we all know that the broad
broad majority of those are are
white supremacists people uh targeting
people of color and immigrants and
things like that but he
brought the other side of the equation
into it by referring to the
shooting of the congressional baseball
practice and he did it very carefully by
saying
a shooting by someone only who committed
a shooting only
after he confirmed that the players were
republican so
i think that reflects the fact that the
fbi still doesn't exactly
know what that shooter was up to they
never
really uncovered the sort of detailed
evidence
that laid out a specific plot or an
objective but it is undeniable
that he was targeting republicans it was
really uh i thought very effective
what what
the fbi never discovered what a specific
objective was
yet it's undeniable that he was
targeting republicans
um andy that's the objective
total incoherence
and this is what happens when when these
ideologues are absolutely committed
to the notion ahead of time that the
greatest threat though
the greatest violent threat we face
right-wing extremists
that has to be the case no matter what
that's what would bring someone like
mccabe he could sit there and say
yeah he was targeting republican
politicians he actually asked ahead of
time
are these republicans and then pulled
out the guns and started shooting
but still we don't really know what he
was doing
that is as clear as it could possibly be
if even after that you can't know his
motive then you can't know anyone's
motive
you certainly can't declare the motives
of these alleged white supremacists
if that's not clear enough what possibly
could be clear enough
and of course mccabe also says that
everybody knows that the
the greatest threat are these white
groups that are targeting people of
color and immigrants
really everyone knows that because i
don't
you you make it sound like this is
happening all the time every day
well please start listing examples
give me um i don't know given that this
is
the greatest threat bigger threat than
blm bigger threat than antifa
can you give me from the last year i
don't know uh
10 examples five
two of this sort of thing
i don't think you can all right moving
on like i said we got a lot to cover and
i'm just trying to
blow through as many of these as i can
this is from i wanted to mention this
briefly from the website uprocks it says
a recent study conducted by the
annenberg
inclusion initiative at the university
of southern california found that
muslims are
woefully underrepresented in film the
report
um which is titled missing and maligned
the reality of muslims in popular global
movies discovered that in 200 popular
films released between
2017 and 2019 in the united states uk
australia and new zealand muslims
account for only 1.6
of speaking roles to break it down even
further quote while muslims make up 24
of the global population they made up
less than 2 percent of the films
researched
meaning out of 8 965 speaking characters
and 200 movies
144 were muslim of the 144 muslim
characters about 34 were muslim women
this according to uso usa today
uh and this is a big problem that we
have to of course solve
a lack of muslim representation in film
the reason i mention this is that it's a
it perfectly illustrates uh how
nonsensical this
modern idea of representation is
especially when it comes to film
first of all you notice what they did
there they're looking at
films in the us uk australia and
one other country right and to show that
there's an underrepresentation
they tell us that the global percentage
of muslims is 24 percent
well 24 muslims on the globe only two
percent in these movies
yeah but you weren't looking at movies
globally
if you included films that were made in
muslim majority countries i'm sure that
percentage would go up
but you specifically didn't do that
because you're trying to build this case
um because in reality let's just take
the united states for example
and i can't tell you off the top of my
head what the percentage of
muslims in the uk is for example it's
going to be higher significantly higher
than is the united states but the united
states
i think the the percentage of by
population
of muslims united states is probably one
percent
around there very small
and so what does representation mean
representation means
if muslims are being proportionally
represented in film
then that means that they would show up
in films really rarely
because they show up in the population
rarely
one percent is very small so if you're
rarely seeing muslims in films in the
united states that means that muslims
are being
properly represented because they are a
small minority
that's what representation means now if
you have one percent of the population
and you want them to be in 10 of films
you're not looking for representation
you're looking for something quite a bit
more than that
you're what you're calling for is a
massive exponential
over representation and so be honest
about what you're calling for
and the other thing that is that's
that's always lost in these
discussions about representation is uh
the the small matter of
choice right people make choices
we hear the same thing when it comes to
women in the workplace
and we're told women make 78 cents on
the dollar which is
totally false but
it is true that women oftentimes will go
to
lower paying professions and we're told
that this is a big problem
but once again you're taking choice out
of the equation do you ever consider
that maybe women
go into those kinds of professions
because that's what they want to do
muslims are
underrepresented in film in the united
states but i guarantee you if we look at
doctors engineers
those sorts of professions the stem
field
they're going to be overrepresented what
does that tell us it means that
in a lot of muslim family families and
in muslim culture
they put an emphasis on those kinds of
professions and not as much of an
emphasis on the arts
not true across the board but generally
speaking
is that a problem what are you saying we
should have fewer muslims
we need to siphon some of the muslim
doctors off and put them in movies
instead
no people make choices and uh that's
perfectly fine
i got one tick tock video we gotta play
it i'm sorry i can't i cannot go into
vacation knowing that my last show we
didn't play a tick tock video
it wouldn't feel right to me so um here
we have a tick tock of a
of a woman white woman explaining why
fat phobia
is racist so listen up here's your
reminder that fat phobia is rooted in
racism
as always if you haven't read this book
go do that
the main thing to understand is that for
the last 300-ish years
white folks have been marketing fatness
as a black trait
and this is regardless of whether or not
black people individually were actually
fat
that was irrelevant the message they
spread was that black women specifically
were ravenous and uncontrollable
and these barbaric traits made them fat
on the flip side
thinness was marketed as a white trait
again regardless of whether or not
individual white people were actually
thin
that was irrelevant the idea was that
white women specifically were refined
and restrained
and this led them to having delicate
thin bodies over the years these
messages have become more subtle but
even today they are still very prevalent
in conversations around race health
capitalism and poverty
this this is the irony of these uh of
the woke set
is that in the effort to dispel what
they
call racist stereotypes they're
spreading
those oftentimes inventing the
stereotypes
um and spreading them
in an effort to dispel them so this is
another example of that
here's you say and she's not the only
one making this claim and she's
referring to a book
the stereotype that's um that black
people are fat
that's wrong i've never even heard of
that before that's i i've
that's an association i've never made
i've never i've never heard of that
stereotype
until the woke people started saying it
until they got up there and said hey you
know not all black people are fat okay
okay who said they were
i think you meant to put that in your
diary or something this is not that's
not for for
this to say the public don't project
your own
issues your own biases onto everybody
else
if i were to if someone told me imagine
a fat person
[Music]
probably if i would imagine a fat white
guy that's the first thing to probably
pop into my mind
i don't spend a lot of time imagining
fat people but if i did that's what i
would do
i wouldn't immediately go to a black but
even that i don't know maybe that's
racist too
because the other part of this is that
we're also told
that fat is beautiful and fat is a good
thing it's a positive thing it's nothing
to be ashamed of
and so if that's the case then even if
someone did have this stereotypical
notion
that black people are more likely to be
fat or whatever it is
isn't it a compliment according to you
fat is beautiful
what are you saying that black people
aren't beautiful is that what you're
saying
seems to be a little bit conflict there
bit of a conflict um
and uh no in in reality uh obesity is
not a racial thing
and it's pretty simple really if you eat
many more calories than you burn you're
gonna get fat and gain weight whatever
your race is
it's a that is a problem that cuts
across all racial boundaries
and oftentimes uh i'll meet someone they
ask me for what i
what i do for a living and uh i'm
offended that they don't already know
uh and then i tell them and then they
they ask me you know why should i watch
your show like
why do i have to explain myself to you
in the first place i'm very bad at
this self-promotion as you can probably
tell but if i had to answer it it's
number one for the conservative
commentary but number two probably most
important
it's to get a load and get a sight of my
glorious
beautiful beard and i know all of you
you know you you want the same you want
the same in your life that kind of beard
and what i tell you what you need is
upkeep okay you can't just let it grow
and neglect it
you have to make sure you're taking care
of the beard as it's growing and that's
why you need beardsupply.com
beardsupply.com has all the top quality
beard products men like these products
for their beards women like these
products
on their men and for a limited time when
you go to beardsupply.com and use code
walsh you get 50
off your first month when you subscribe
to one of their already affordable beard
oils costing you less than eight dollars
not only does 50 of your first month
sound great
but subscribing comes with its own perks
as well you get your product of choice
automatically delivered every one two or
three months it's your choice and you
never have to worry about running out of
product ever again and remember use code
walsh for 50
off your first month of the subscription
so go sign up right now
and i wish you the best in your beard
growing endeavors again that's
beardsupply.com
all right let's go now to reading the
youtube comments this is for uh from
jrcrash says abuela's ghost
sounds like an awesome name for a band
it does actually
i'll agree with you there maximilian
says matt i think you should change the
title of your show to the bad news with
matt walsh i
the more i thought i think about it came
to me yesterday in a moment of
inspiration
i only have those every once in a while
more thing about the more i like it
uh i don't know if the powers that be
here would would necessarily like that
kind of branding for the show
the bad news um
because there aren't very many people
who if you're selling the show that way
would actually want to click on that and
watch it or listen to it
yeah let me get some more of that bad
news see i would but i think most people
probably would
um another comment says referring to me
calling the presidency the most
stressful job on the planet says matt
you're too smart for that people don't
pay 100 million dollars
in campaigns to be the most stressed
person on the planet
yeah the most stressful job on the
planet obviously hyperbole
um but it is a stressful job being the
president
it doesn't mean that that all of our
presidents have done the job well or
even most of them have done it well
but there's no denying that it is a
physically and mentally stressful job i
don't think there's any way around that
and all you have to do is look at the
physical transformations of
[Music]
pretty much every president in my in the
modern times except for trump
he's the only one who came out looking
the same as he did going in
but all the rest of them look like they
aged 20 years
in the oval office doesn't mean they
were doing a great job
but it's obviously a
very stressful position we're out in
front of the entire world
and you have a lot of a great amount of
power and responsibility and everything
else
and that's why you probably don't want
someone who's
80 years old to be dealing with that
level of stress
if if the job aged obama
and bush 20 years in eight years what's
it gonna do to someone who's already 80
or 78 um
trail price says matt i think it's about
time we address the alien
in the room i don't know what in the
world you're possibly referring to
uh and finally edward and jessica say
thank you matt i really needed to feel
even more nervous about my flight on
friday yeah we were talking yesterday
about all the
the violent incidents on on airplanes
have skyrocketed recently
on top of that it's more expensive than
ever you have to wear a mask
and that's why i you know you're taking
a flight i will do anything
if i if i had to go across the ocean i
would we would go across in a row boat
rather than rather than take a plane at
this point
well we've got drag queens singing to
our children uh on nickelodeon we've got
little girls being encouraged to twerk
in the street which we'll talk about in
just a second the left is uh we know
trying to uh wipe out our culture as it
once was and replace it with a brand of
woke authoritarianism
and we have to stop them and that's why
you need to pick up ben shapiro's new
book the authoritarian moment and learn
about
how we got to this place as a society
and where we can go from here so if you
if you understand the threat this poses
to our future it's time to read up
on the truth and stop the nonsense in
its tracks the authoritarian moment is
now available for pre-order at amazon
barnes and noble or any other major
bookseller you know it's no secret also
that the left is a cult which uh
and cults are notoriously hard to leave
however some do
find the strength to get out georgia
howe is one of those people
a former teacher and liberal georgia
howe saw the ideological indoctrination
sweeping the nation took a stand against
it which you can now listen to or do
uh anywhere uh anytime on her podcast
office hours from discussing critical
race theory to transgenderism to
all the woke nonsense in her school
she's really good on that topic
especially
you get all of that with office hours
with georgia howe so subscribe and
download office hours with georgia howe
on apple podcast or
whatever your platform of choice happens
to be and get ready for the ultimate
listening experience
no matter where you are now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
all right matt hold on for me for just
one moment uh we need to come in and
make an adjustment
happy birthday dear man
happy birthday to
you
i'm generally opposed to birthdays as
you all know but i'll make an exception
on my own case
so thank you all for that what am i
supposed to do blow this out
it doesn't seem very coveted safe but
it took me pathetic all right
thank you thoroughly embarrassed and i
appreciate it thank you
so we still doing the show or today for
our daily cancellation
i'm gonna cancel everyone involved in
that unseemly display
um but i also have something that's uh
that uh hopefully requires
little explanation and i think it really
speaks for itself
and i have to admit i i struggle
with this with whether to show this kind
of thing or talk about it
because on one hand i don't want to call
attention to it and contribute
unintentionally to the problem but on
the other hand i don't want to ignore
the abuse of a child and let it go and
criticize and that brings us to
this viral video as reported by the
blaze quote
a video of a crowd applauding and
encouraging a young girl who's twerking
in the street in new york city
outraged many on social media who called
it abusive and immoral
the video was posted to a twitter
account but originated from an account
on tick tock called your fave african
fa whatever that is it shows a very
young girl twerking while the crowd
records videos applauds
and laughs the original video was first
posted to tick-tock and only garnered
207 000 views
far fewer than those on the same video
posted to twitter and before i go any
further i'll show you the video just so
you understand
what we're dealing with here and here it
is
we all need this confidence in life
[Music]
now as the blaze alluded to plenty of
people were rightfully outraged by that
video the sexualization of a child by a
group of cheering adults
is the kind of thing that should provoke
outrage in the hearts and minds of all
good and decent people we shouldn't
react to
we shouldn't react to the perpetual
outrage culture
as some do by deciding that apathy is
the best course
as if outrage in and of itself is the
problem
that's been the defense mechanism of
many people including many on the right
who wish to demonstrate their
non-leftist
bonafides by not objecting to or showing
any anger towards
our cultural decay now that that's the
wrong approach to put it mildly
the problem with outrage just as with
canceled culture is that it often
targets the wrong things
and it's wielded in the wrong ways i'm
not against people being outraged nor am
i against
getting people getting or things getting
canceled obviously
i'm against both of those when they're
disordered improper misapplied or
fraudulent or some combination
of the four but not everybody was
outraged by the video it did have its
defenders including a guy named pete
dominic
who apparently is a comedian of some
sort and
he came after me and accused me of being
worse than the taliban
because i said that the adults in that
video should be arrested
actually in fairness i said that if i
ever run for president my one promise is
that i will arrest all adults involved
in that sort of thing and that sort of
thing being the sexualization of
children
that's not entirely true though i would
do a few other things as well as
president
like build a 300-foot statue of
christopher columbus in the middle of dc
just out of spite
um and i'd ban u.s embassies from flying
pride flags or any flag that isn't an
american flag
i might do a few other things too but
certainly criminalizing the abuse and
exploitation of children in all forms
and imprisoning the abusers would be at
the top of the list
for this dominic accused me of being
worse than the taliban
and then he went on to argue that there
isn't anything necessarily wrong with
young children
twerking on the street corner and he's
not alone in that view
obviously he's not alone as the young
child in the video was surrounded by
adults
who clearly felt at the the same way
about the situation
what we have to understand about a video
like that
is that it's not an aberration it's not
something that happens out of the blue
in an otherwise decent and morally
adjusted culture
now this is born from primarily two
factors
one the blurring of lines blurring of
the lines of distinction between adults
and children
in our culture kids are routinely
exposed to all kinds of
degeneracy that even adults in prior
generations would have never seen or
heard or encountered in any form
and now kids at very young ages are
exposed to it
meanwhile kids are given power and
agency that they are not equipped to
handle as discussed in the opening
they're given the power even to decide
their own identity
so the idea of the innocence and naivete
of children has been lost meanwhile two
the role of adults of parents has been
similarly blurred into oblivion
many parents these days think that their
job is simply to facilitate their
children's choices
whatever those choices happen to be and
ensure at least a basic level of
physical safety maybe as the kids go
about living however they want to live
and doing whatever they want to do
this is the kind of environment that
we've created and it gives rise to
many terrible things uh that video being
just one
rotten fruit from that tree i hope i
don't have to go any further to explain
the problem with what we just witnessed
or to justify myself in saying
that all of the adults involved there
are cancelled
and quite a lot more would happen to
them if i was in a position of authority
which fortunately for uh for everyone
probably i never will be
and we'll leave it there for today um
and for the next several days
i wish you all well as you're working in
the drudgery and toil of your jobs
um i'll be enjoying my vacation the best
that one can with four kids
and i'll see you back in a little bit
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show a video of shoplifter
in san francisco draws national
attention to the city's massive
property crime spree and the biden
administration declares white supremacy
america's greatest domestic violence
threat that's today on the bench bureau
show give it a listen